[Music]
how do you mourn the loss of your
marriage while staying in it you've
created a world that you can't win in
I'm at my breaking point in this
marriage I think you've lived scared to
death for so long has he hurt you do you
think your husband's going to kill
[Music]
you what in the world is going on this
is John of the Dr John deloney
show it's 9:00 on a Saturday regular
crowd shuffles in dud I'm so glad you're
with us it's not Saturday but I am glad
that you're with us we're talking mental
health emotional health marriage we're
talking everything going on in your life
parenting kids whatever if you want to
be on this show my promise is I'm going
to sit with you and this is a show about
real people going through real stuff
I'll sit with you and we will figure out
what to do next go to johal.com
[Music]
askk or give me a buzz at 84469 33291
leave a message Jenna will listen to it
she'll probably delete it Kelly will get
it out of the deleted files she will
read it and then pass it to Joe who will
make a final decision is that how that
goes not in any
way not even a little bit nope not not
really even close I could I was I read
them first then they go to Jenna no no
offense to Joe but he doesn't really
have much to do with that
process I could see that
darn that's the most words I've heard
Joe say in the last calendar year oh man
um and hey don't forget save your
holidays questions for humans at John
dooney.com pick up the deck all of them
all of them all right let's go to htown
where they're still mourning go Rangers
should be a World Series Victory all
right let's go to Ashley what's up
Ashley hello what's
up hi Dr johnone thank you for having me
on your show you got it Ashley what's up
um so my question is how do you mourn
the loss of your marriage while staying
in
it
um so basically we're together and we're
raising a family but we're not
together why we're not seeing other
people but we're
not do you want to
be of
course does the person you're married to
want to
be um if he does he doesn't show like
talk into the phone for me talk into the
phone his words and his action don't say
that um
I beged for counseling I beg for I mean
we can do anything a book a podcast a
whatever he wants to come up with um to
try to like
rekindle but I mean ultimately
like everything I'm trying is being met
with nothing nothingness on his end and
I'm to the point that it's like I just
need to get over him but I'm going to be
with him for a long time so it's hard to
get over somebody you see every day why
have you done that to
yourself why are you choosing this this
path
forward because I have no ideas like
what else to do going um I wanted to see
a therapist but it's not financially in
the books nor do I I have child care for
that
um I stay home with the babies and my
husband work yeah I I I don't I'm going
to say this it's going to sound harsh
but I don't believe
that I believe you stay at
home I believe that you've could figure
out a way to get to a counselor in fact
I'm going to take that excuse from you
I'm going to give you three months of
free better help counseling every week
that you can do at your
home how do you do it with kids cuz I'm
like I'm the primary parent so how old
are your kids one and three do they not
take
naps um they're napping right now but I
haven't figured out how to get them to
nap where I get more than like 30
minutes okay like I guess aone time do
you have a friend with a 10-year-old who
could come over and
play why don't you a pretty antisocial
person which I am social I take my kids
to do things but I haven't really met
people I guess and my only um like I
guess friend that I talk to has a
newborn and a one-year-old or a
two-year-old now okay she and my parents
she can help out when they can
but you've created a world that you
can't win
in and you've created a world that
um where you are this
sole victim inside of this trapped house
and I don't buy
it I think you could do different things
why why are you why are you thinking so
little of
yourself I don't know I guess it's just
a a habit I've gotten
into but please don't you're worth more
than
this
everything you're involved with is worth
more than
this your original question you don't
mourn a marriage and just like you're CH
you're CH you're mourning is something
that happens when something
dies are you telling me that right now
this early in your marriage you're
choosing
death I mean it's not super early we're
13 years in
but um I'm not I feel like I have to
choose it I feel like if I I mean I've
beged I've pleed and if you not
interested like what am I what am I
supposed to do love myself only and
pretend like it's him that loves
me no behavior is a language he has left
you he's just too much of a coward to
say it out
loud well sometimes you need to hear it
he has stopped being married to
you or I'll even say it this way he is
cheating on you with
silence yeah like a th% like we're fine
with all the big stuff I guess in life
like working through finances and I
guess the normal stuff people fight
about those aren't the big things the
big things are do you love
me the big things are I'm watching my
wife drown and I don't know how to
help yeah and I've used those words like
especially at night when I'm at my Wit's
End and I'm also pregnant and do with
our third at the beginning of the year
and I'm
like sometimes I just need a minute and
I'll tell him that and he doesn't get it
or doesn't care is the way I perceive it
and like how am I supposed to see
somebody to help me figure out me when I
mean even showers are hard at this point
of course so what you're like just so
I'm
clear when your husband comes
home and you have a three- year-old and
a one-year-old and you're very very
pregnant and you start and you say how's
your day and he said fine how's yours
and you say it was good um I need 30
minutes by myself I need you to watch
the little ones for 30 minutes I got a
shower I haven't showered haven't gone
to the bathroom yet
today and he goes I'm not doing
that no he says of course you do and
acts like annoyed and it's not that he's
annoyed to play with the kids because he
he's super great with the kids like
comes home and plays with them and um
but my youngest right now has become my
velcro baby and so she cries and instead
of him trying to like divert her
attention to something outside or do
something else and he just gets
frustrated because she's going through
whatever she's going through right now
and then I feel guilty and I'm like well
then just forget it because I don't want
to put her through
that sweetheart I mean
one-year-olds want their moms and they
cry
sometimes and when dads are frustrated
intense kids feel the tension and the
frustration and they cry
more but if every time your kid cries
and doesn't learn how to be close to Dad
and Dad doesn't learn how to get some
little wins with this
one-year-old and you feel guilty and
come rescue him and Rescue
her you can't then turn around and play
the
Martyr just let her be in that kind of
yes and then say
offline hey here's two or three or four
things that really help when she's
crying like
that I see you trying hard and I know
it's hard when that baby just won't stop
crying and when she's just stuck to me
like GL I get that it's hard try these
couple of
things what he usually does is let her
scream at the bathroom
door and it's like hard for me to take a
shower or if she's just screaming at me
at the baby gate while I'm trying to
cook dinner I can't have her with me
because it's dangerous or
something and he won't come
help I mean he'll say he'll call her a
name and tell her to come back to him
but he doesn't actually like physically
get her and distract her which I feel
like is I
mean I guess is what I do so I feel like
that's what's best because of that age
but maybe that's not what's best maybe
letting them just no try it out at G not
what I'm saying at all not what I'm
saying at all I'm saying that it sounds
like a dad who's either a a terrible
human
being an absolute
lazy no good husband SL
father who is so lazy he won't even get
up and pick up his one-year-old who
scaming her brains out why mom's cooking
dinner or mom's trying to go to the
bathroom that's either that or he's a
dad without any tools in his
toolkit no he's a he's a horrible
husband he's an amazing father I mean he
lets him cry or whatever but like
like just a different parenting style
than I have I guess why haven't why
haven't youall talked about
that I what do you I guess I don't know
what what do you say
he in my house my wife was super helpful
because I never Babys sat I had never
changed a diaper
before I didn't know what I was
doing oh no I give him all the tips like
I'll even say hey will you take them out
and swing them so I can get XYZ done and
what does he
say like he doesn't feel like
it where he like I feel like it's more
like a control thing where he doesn't
want to take my tips
because he feels like I'm controlling
the situation and he wants to watch the
kids how he wants to watch the kids and
that's maybe it's the way I come across
maybe it's the verbiage I use but it's
not my intention I just want my kids not
to cry at
me so so and and I'm trying to get
somewhere offline when the kids are
finally asleep and you crash on the
couch and he crashed
es and you've turned and looked at him
and said hey we're not
okay yeah he says hold on be quiet I'm
trying to watch
TV no he gets frustrated
or like half the time he'll just fall
asleep mid conversation and I tell him
like I'm like I'm at my breaking point
in this marriage I'm tired of being
lonely I'm tired of feeling like I'm
doing this all on my own
like I
mean and he doesn't really a lot of
times he doesn't respond he just like
will stare at me I'm not doing this with
you today or whatever that's it like I
feel like he just walks up super tight
and doesn't want to talk about
anything but well here's the deal he's
not here I'm a talker so I don't know
how to get through any of it without
talking and figuring it out that's
that's good but he's not
here so I'll ask you why haven't you
packed up and gone to your parents'
house if you have kids that are
screaming and a husband that won't help
that won't listen that looks at you and
says I'm not even I'm not even going to
honor you with a
response I'm just going to fall asleep
while you're
talking I'm not even going to listen to
your helpful tips even though you're
with the kids all day and I'm clearly
struggling why haven't you just gone to
your parents why are you choosing to
model this for your kids this is this
kids is what love looks
like um
because there's a whole
another aspect to the
story that your call probably doesn't
for but basically he can be uh very
vindictive and mean and I don't want my
kids thinking for
me why would your kids get taken from
you because he has a violent
history they wouldn't take them from you
they would take them from him has he
hurt
you in the
past why are you still
there
because I do love him and I don't want
to be I don't know Ashley You're Not
Safe You're Not
Safe those kids aren't
safe are you involved in something that
if came to light they would take your
kids away from you are you struggling
with
addiction
no then why would
anybody you what I don't have any I
don't have any of those thing vices if
you will okay they usually don't take in
fact they never
take but if I'm not
alive
because he chose to getting rid of me
then where my baby's goingon to go do
you think your husband's going to kill
you I don't I don't put myself in that
situation anymore let me be super clear
with let me be super clear with you I'm
about to call the local police in your
area you can't call the show and tell me
that you're scared for your life and
have me just do nothing I'm not I'm only
scared first of all I love him and I
want it to be with him okay he doesn't
want to be with you Ashley he doesn't
want to be with
you right
[Music]
so my only option is to leave I'm asking
you you're telling me he won't talk to
you he won't listen to you he won't
engage with
you you're scared for your you're scared
for your
life relationship stuff well you're
drowning you're dying you called me on I
how to mourn something how to be
dead I guess I was just hoping there was
a happy ending somewhere if I could just
find a way to be at peace with the cards
I was
dealt the cards I
chose because those cards aren't static
you can hand those cards back to the
dealer and get another
set
but you can't you absolutely can't no
you can get back out there and raise
your kids all alone and be that
potentially person but you're not going
to find like I don't feel like you can
find anybody decent this day and age I
think that's 1,000%
incorrect it's not even close to
reality and I know that because I talk
to him every single day every
day here's what I think I think you've
lived scared to death for so
long I think you're so
exhausted I think you've got another
baby on the
way and that terrifies
you and as you said at the beginning of
the call you like to socially
isolate and your body is screaming at
you that you're not safe and you're all
by
yourself and when that happens sometimes
the whole world gets real
dim and so if you call me my hope that
you called is because you trust me and
I'm telling
you there is hope and there is light and
there are people that will help but you
have to be willing to take their
help and you have to be willing to say
I'm tired of living like this and I want
to do something
different when you're
safe then you
grieve I didn't want my marriage to look
like this I didn't want to be with a guy
that was unsafe I didn't want my kids to
grow up like this I didn't want to be a
single mom with three little
ones I didn't want to have to go to a
bunch of counseling and try to fix this
thing I don't even mind all that I just
want to to help me back I
know I
know here's the deal here's what we're
gonna do couple things number
one Jenna's gonna ask you very
specifically offline if you're
safe if there are any threats on your
life
if there are we're calling the police
period end of
discussion number two we're going to get
you some free counseling with our
friends at better
help and you might have to call somebody
over to your house for 30 minutes to
watch your kid let somebody love
you you have to hear me say the greatest
gift you can give your kids right now is
that their mom is safe and
whole and that means the greatest gift
is not letting them you
know racing in there every time x y or Z
happens it's making sure you talk to a
professional therapist right
now it's making sure the police are
involved if you're not safe or if this
person is
violent it's reaching out to your mom
and dad no you didn't want that but here
we
are
the third thing is you got to go sit
with your mom and with your dad if
they're safe and say I need some
help and it might be asking him to leave
and if that's not safe or smart then you
pack up and say I got to be out here for
30 days while we figure out what's next
and if he calls and flips out and you
say I've tried to tell you that I'm not
safe in this marriage that I'm not okay
in this marriage and if we're going to
be back together we got to build
something
new but you don't just cash
out that quiet life of desperation this
is just the way this
is cuz people do change especially when
they get new
tools the sun come up and if worst comes
to worse there are some amazing people
out in the
world in this quote unquote day and
age
[Music]
there's a lot going on here and you need
to get to a professional
ASAP please please please make that call
today taking away all the barriers for
you want you to make that call hang on
the line and Jenna's going to pick up
we'll be right
back this episode is sponsored by Better
Health hey it's delone what in the world
is going on listen this is that time of
year Family Trav travel everyone telling
you what to do the end of the year
fiscal season money politics all of it
and all of it's happening in the dark
because the sun goes down and it doesn't
seem to want to come up Seasonal
effective disorder is real so you put
Darkness on top of all of it and wow it
gets dark at 4:30 where I live and I'm
ready for bed at 5:45 in the evening
things aren't as fun sometimes even my
food tastes different but now I know I
got to take care of my body I got to get
outside even when it's dark outside or
even when it's early in the morning I
got to move my body I got to put bright
lights in my eyes and I have to
intentionally connect with people and
sometimes intentionally connecting with
people is about friends and other times
intentionally connecting with people is
with therapy therapy can be a bright
spot in the chaos at the end of the year
even when the sun goes down too soon
something to help you feel positive and
grounded and give you tools to manage
all this
madness when nothing else will so if
you're thinking of starting therapy give
betterhelp a try better help is flexible
because it's totally online and it can
fit into any schedule you have just fill
out a short questionnaire you're going
to get matched with the licensed
therapist and you could switch therapist
at any time for no charge find your
bright spot in the chaos find some peace
When Everything feels like it's spinning
out of control with my friends at better
help visit betterhelp.com delone today
to get 10% off your first month that's
betterhelp
hp.com dealone you're worth
it all right let's go out to Chattanooga
and talk to Ethan what's up
Ethan hey Dr deloney thanks so much of
course man what's up
so um I'm a school teacher um and my
wife and I have been following the baby
steps um since the beginning of this
last summer um my wife and I have been
working really really hard um trying to
push trying to find extra ways to gain
income and um we're able to put about
$2,000 a month um towards our dead we've
got about $25,000 left in our Dead
awesome hey real quick real quick Ethan
let me tell everybody so if you're
listening to this and you don't know
what he's talking about with baby step
um my friend Dave Ramsey has a program
called Financial Peace University where
he has been helping people get out of
debt millions of millions and millions
of people get out of debt for for three
decades now for 30 years plus and so
Ethan you and your wife are working to
get out of debt right to be to become
free financially free and y'all are
working that program and y'all figure
out away on a teacher salary and
whatever your wife does to have an extra
2,000 bucks a month youall aren't going
to restaurants youall aren't going um
out on fancy dates you're not going on
vacations you're just trying to pay all
this stuff off right yes sir that is
correct pretty amazing that's awesome
okay well thank you um well my my
grandmother who's been like a mother
figure to me uh my my entire life I I I
come unfortunately from kind of A
Dysfunctional Family background um has
offered to let us come in with her
temporarily to help get us out of debt
she wants us be able to to double the
amount of money we can throw each month
at our debt and um I have been
struggling really really hard my wife is
100% supportive she is entirely behind
me and behind the idea of us moving she
loves my grandmother to death um but I
am struggling greatly with anxiety uh in
regards to this and I'm extremely
bothered by it because this is my
grandmother the closest person that I am
to other than my wife and I I'm not sure
where it's stemming from I am very
afraid to move out of my home we rent a
house it's it's not even hours but um
I've lived there for the last three and
a half years my wife and I when we got
married nearly two years ago uh she
moved into the house with me and just
since I've moved out of my mother's nine
or 10 years ago I've finally had a
stable life and been on my own and I'm
just extremely scared um to move in with
her and just to leave everything I know
everything I'm comfortable with and I
just was curious to know what you could
share just how do I how do I cope with
this anxiety and just whether or not it
would be a good idea for us in the long
run to make the choice to move in with
her temporarily to pay off this dead
sure so
um whenever somebody tells me they're
anxious my first thought is good good
for
you your body's working great to protect
you from something or from several
things and embedded in your answer I
think might be one of the the
solutions sounds like you grew up in a
chaotic
mess and your
grandmother was your Lifeline Fair yes
100% And then you got a
job and then you got
married then you got your own
place and your body felt and experienced
something it has never felt
before which was
peace and then this opportunity shows up
that I kind of want to be honest no I
want to be totally honest kind of sounds
like it's a benefit to you and your
wife and it's kind of a benefit to your
grandmother and wouldn't surprise me
that the woman who saved
you also needed you to be okay because
she had some guilt about what her kids
had
done and so in the same on one hand God
you're so blessed and and lucky to have
a grandmother that came for
you and you've been a Xanax for
her you made sure she was going to be
all right Fair yes sir
okay sounds to me like your body's
working real real
well now the question you have to decide
is 25,000 bucks left that means at
Christmas 2024 y'all are going to owe
nobody anything if y'all stay on this
current
trajectory 12 months from now yes sir
one year how old are you I'm 28 okay
when you're 40 you don't even remember
this
year or you work crazy over the summer
and earn another X couple thousand bucks
doing X Y and Z and you move this thing
up to September of next
year that's one thing you look at your
wife and you say you know what we're
building our own life our own home great
we're just going to keep knocking it out
and you know what that path is going to
be
hard but y'all proven to yourselves you
can do it or sell sell everything leave
your rent house move in with Grandma
both the good and the
bad and accelerate this debt payoff when
are you going to be done if you moved in
with your
grandma we we would uh we looked at the
debt calculator and it said June
okay so it sounds like it'll knock about
three or four months
off is that about right yes sir
okay is that worth
it I would think so um just because my
wife and I are so ready to move on from
this step we've been you know struggling
with it I mean not as long as others you
know praise the Lord but
nonetheless it's it it does have it does
have a a strain on our marriage that
we're not able to move Beyond uh this
and move into the next you know baby
step or phase of our life but make it
make it make it I mean be super clear
it's GNA be a strand on your marriage
moving with your grandma yes and it's
going to be a strand on your marriage if
you both decide to get um start driving
Uber after you get done teaching school
and you do that until 10:00 and you all
get this thing done by June on your
own which is
possible
yes I've got to a place in my life where
and I should have said this earlier it's
going to be hard to stay the course in
your rent house it's also going to be
hard to move in with your
grandma you got some demons there right
I do yeah and that doesn't mean she's
not amazing that doesn't mean she didn't
save your life that doesn't mean any of
those things all that can be true at
same
time but that's going to be hard also so
the path forward
is which hard are you going to
choose and anytime I'm faced with that
that
decision I want to choose the hard path
that is going to give me two things the
most freedom and
autonomy and the most strength on the
other
side
and the way you've lined it out for me
if you guys stay where you are and
choose to double down on working even
more than you already
work and you decide I want this thing
done by July July 1 and I see a path
forward if I earn this much extra money
delivering pizzas or doing whatever
working the night shift um working from
8:00 p.m. to 11:00 p.m. throwing boxes
or 6 p.m. to midnight throwing boxes and
then I teach the next day mhm
whatever on the back end of
that you're free you don't live with
somebody you don't have to have the hard
conversation about well it's time to
move out well are you sure you got to
move out cuz my feet hurt and I really
need your help on you avoid all
that and if you need to take a weekend
off from working three jobs or four jobs
while you're also teaching you can but
you can't take a weekend off from
Grandma's
house H so so that path is free and on
the back end you know you and your wife
know after a lifetime of chaos a
lifetime of trying to figure out how to
stand up on your own two feet and stare
down some of these
demons you're going to hold her hand and
know nothing can knock y'all
down yeah and it's it's just uh
extremely tough just because I've um
never been a decisive individual and
it's really hard always been hard for me
to choose and here's what's cool hold on
here's what's cool there is no wrong
answer here there's only two hard
paths that's
it if you choose Ethan like you know
what we're staying the course I'm
staying here honey I'm gon to work like
crazy and by the way you're going to
miss me in the evenings when I'm working
this second job but if I move in with we
move in with Grandma you're gonna miss
me because I'm going to be up having tea
or coffee or whatever with
Grandma and you're G to wish that we
were our sex life was better and we were
spending time watching TV you're going
to wish that if we lived at Grandma's
house because we're not going to be
rocking till the wheels fall off at
Grandma's house
right right I just made this podcast
weird for everybody I realize that
but if you get three months down the
road and your body just starts falling
apart on you I just can't work until
midnight and get up at 6: am and go be a
teacher all day which by the way I think
you
can then you move with
Grandma but you will have blown your
whole life apart you'll have got rid of
your home you'll have got rid of your
furniture you got rid of your stuff and
you move in with Grandma for three
months and realize this isn't working
out there's it's going to be a much more
difficult path to
untangle and by the way this idea of
decisiveness it's been uncomfortable for
you to stand on two feet it's my guess
growing up when you made a decision you
got hit in a mouth for it or the adults
in your life took your decisions and
flushed them down the toilet and so your
body has learned over time don't make a
decision because you just complicate
things for everybody when you do path
out of that is a whole bunch of little
winds if you can't do a pull-up
cool get on a chair and climb all the
way up until you're in pull-up
position and just five times a day just
slow as you can release yourself
down then get up and do it again and
then get up and do it again what we're
going to do is we're going to take a
pullup and we're going to pull it apart
into a bunch of little pieces and we're
going to do those little pieces until
one day I can pull my myself up one time
and I'm going to scream and cheer that I
got one pullup
in then I'm going to keep
going and suddenly after six months a
year you could do 10 at a time you can
do 20 at a time without
stopping that's how you build strength
the path out of this anxiousness
feeling the nerd word is exposure I'm
going to slowly head into the storm so
my body says hey you don't make
decisions I'm making this
one and lucky for me there's not a wrong
answer hey hey hey you can't work two
jobs I'm gonna give it a shot you
watch you're going to be in debt forever
you watch I'm cutting this time in
half the calculator says uh 10 months
cool I'm going to do it in six what has
to be true for me and my wife and our
work schedules for us to be done in six
I'm going to build it that way and then
on the back end you're going to have
taught your your body n you can make
decisions you're going to have taught
your body D you can work crazy hours for
a short season to accomplish a goal
you're going to have taught your
wife that guy's way stronger than I
thought he was you're going to have
taught you that you're way stronger than
you
were personally I like that
path there is a season to sell your
house and move in with your mom move in
with your grandma I get that but just
from this little conversation my
recommendation if you were my brother or
you my friend I would say hey get Gnarly
and stay the course and on the back end
you'll have
freedom and you're going to be stronger
than you ever thought
imaginable hang on the line I'm going to
send you a copy of building a
non-anxious life for you and your wife
to
read start looking at that the whole six
daily choices chart y'all start
following that thing
religiously Little Steps man you got
this holler at me when you pay all your
debts off we'll celebrate you we'll be
right
back hey deloney here and it's pumpkin
spice latte season just kidding that's
disgusting but it is fall it's a little
cooler the sun's going down earlier and
God help us daylight savings time is
ending or starting or whatever the time
is the time is changing again and it can
be exhausting to adjust to everything
all the time so make sure you're moving
your body every day getting sunlight in
the morning and in the evening and
getting 7 to9 hours of sleep each night
I can't stress enough how important this
is sleep is the Cornerstone to physical
and mental and emotional health and for
me great sleep starts with an amazing
mattress that's why I love dreamcloud
and why my family sleeps on dreamcloud
and right now dreamcloud is running an
awesome offer 40% off all mattresses
plus an additional $50 in savings
exclusively for our listeners go to
dreamcloud sleep.com and enter promo
code John deloney that's dreamcloud
sleep.com with code John deloni for 40%
off all mattresses and an extra $50 in
savings all right let's roll out to
Fresno California and talk to Lynn
what's up
Lyn hello hello what's up I'm here hey
Lynn Hi how are you good what's
up okay uh this is a pretty big one um
so my question is uh were my
expectations too much and was I too
insensitive and I'll give you a
backstory go for it on on what happened
so I recently got married uh in
September
and I had asked my best friend to be to
be my M of M honor which she said that
she would do so mind you she work she
lives in Oregon and uh we we've been
best friends for seven years we've lived
together um I'm a Believer and she's not
and so she moved to Oregon with her
boyfriend and they have a
six-month-old and um you know it's been
really hard for her moving up there
she's been financially strapped um so
with that we offered for her to uh come
down here we paid for a roundtrip flight
for her to come to attend the wedding so
it make it a little bit easier on her um
so a month before my wedding she calls
and she tells me that she's not going to
come to the wedding and then I found out
that she was pregnant unexpectedly with
her second child
and she didn't really go more beyond
that on why she couldn't uh or why did
she she decided not to come
and um I just felt like there was more
but as she just wasn't telling me
um so I kind of distanced myself from
her during that time um because you know
I was obviously really busy in planning
a wedding and then just emotionally like
it really hurt me and I did express that
to her a little bit um and then I
reached out to her after the wedding
telling her more how it really hurt me
and that I just needed a little bit of
space to like you know pray and forgive
and move on and then she comes at me
with all of these reasons as to why it
was my fault that she didn't come she
was um I mean she was telling me that
she had a miscarriage which I didn't
even I wasn't even aware about um she
was telling me how financially strapped
they were even
more uh how an emotion how emotionally
she just wasn't capable of leaving her
child
and ultimately I didn't respond to her
right away which even set her off even
more and attacked me even more and when
I did try reaching out to her
she just didn't want any she just didn't
want to talk to me and she wanted her
she needs her
space and I don't really know what to
think about this situation anymore
because I'm not trying to be insensitive
because one point I understand what she
was going through but I don't understand
why she wasn't telling me all that stuff
if I was her best
friend yeah you might not have
been I'm sorry you might not have
been might not have been her best friend
yeah
well I mean we've I have been there for
her for the years that we've been
friends like over the top and she even
mentioned in her message that she
admitted sometimes our friendship was
one-sided that I I was a great friend to
her and you're not hearing what I'm
saying ly
oh sh
she might have been your best
friend but you might not have been
hers oh yeah I I understand that um
behavior is a language I say that a
lot and she made it
clear that she didn't trust you enough
to sit to tell you what she was going
through that's not an indictment on you
I don't even know if that's an
indictment on
her but for whatever reason she gave you
her commitment and then she backed out
and she was unable to tell you why mhm
and
then behavior is a
language she didn't want to talk to you
for a
while and then she let you have
it yeah after you let her have
it and then and then and then
mhm what I can't figure out is if you're
mad that you had this picture of what
this wedding was going to look like and
she messed your picture up because she
wasn't
there or if you're mourning the fact
that this friendship is
over or maybe
both yeah I mean obviously it's not the
same with her with her not being there
and yeah I did imagine it in one way um
but I didn't know all that stuff that
was going on so I know but you didn't
know because she didn't tell you right
exactly which was confusing to me it's
not confusing it's very
easy
either you're not the friend she's not
the friend that you thought she
was or she didn't trust
you it's not confusing
using it's not over dramatic it just
is it sounds very very
painful if one of my closest friends in
the world just called out of the blue
and was like hey man this big thing
that's happening for you I can't be
there why not I just can't dude talk to
me why I'm not going to tell
you that'd be devastating to
me and I would have to make peace with
he gets to do that
and I'm not in super tight relationships
with people who don't trust me it's
cool because I work really hard to be
trustworthy so if you don't want to
trust me okay I'm going to live in that
I'm G have be heartbroken for a while
that
happens but you're giving her a lot of
power over your
life and I mean this like in the most
loving way I can say it but you're
choosing misery right
now which is different than choosing
grief mhm which is different than
choosing to move on you're choosing
anger and rage and
mad instead of choosing to be
heartbroken that your friendship of
seven years almost a
decade it's it's gone now it's not what
it was going to
be yeah that is it's hard to swallow for
sure
yeah but that energy is much better
spent in
grief and working through what comes
next you're married now you're all going
to have a different kind of
life you live in different states you're
going to have to do the hard work of
making friends in your local community
your local area rebuilding trust to
people that you love there or building
it for the first time that's where it's
been my energy
because here's the deal doesn't matter
what I think about if you were over the
top about your wedding that's what you
wanted and you asked your friend and she
said I'm in and then she backed out and
didn't tell you
why that hurts
real yeah it
does but if I'm you I'm not going to go
back another
time
I'm just not yeah because you think it's
going to feel good when you finally get
those final words in and I'm telling you
right now it's going to be a hollow
Victory it won't feel
great yeah that's what my husband's been
telling
me it's the worst when he's right is
it yeah I'm like what about this and
he's like nope he's like it's not going
to end that way you're not going to feel
any better you will not because you
already tried to get your mic drop
moment after the wedding was already
over you called and you told her what's
up and then she was like hold my beer
I'll mic drop
you and then you were like hold on hold
both my beers and this shot I'm gonna
mic drop your mic what are we why what
are we doing yeah
yeah she told you I had this I had this
I had this I had this and oh my gosh you
didn't respond on my my
schedule behavior is a language she's
telling you she does not want to have
the kind of friendship that you want or
need which sucks after all the does all
the years that I've does poured into it
I know but she's not a
401k you don't be nice to somebody so
that one day they're nice back to you oh
of course not yeah of course not but
that's what you did and you're mad that
your investment didn't pay off
M instead of being heartbroken that um
you may have misread this relationship
for a long time or that you look up and
you realize oh this was super one-sided
she even called it out I was kind of a
sucker or yeah man she called out how
oneid of this was I think I was super
nice to her all these years
because I didn't want to be
alone that's a way harder truth to
swallow than oh yeah I'll tell
you right
yeah you got to make peace with what is
owning choosing
reality reality is absent her calling
you and saying hey I blew it I totally
screwed up at a major
loss I don't like being I don't like
living where we
lived my relationship with my boyfriend
I thought it was going to be this cool
new hip modern way of doing love we
don't need marriage we're just going to
have kids and we're going to it's
falling
apart I'm
broke I can't breathe I'm so scared and
I miss you and I took you for granted
she didn't call with
that sounds like you got to make peace
with this thing's over and that's gonna
hurt but choosing rage and choosing
misery is not affecting her day one bit
it's just poisoning you and like the old
Sayan goes you're drinking poison hoping
that she gets sick and she's not she's
an Oregon doing her Oregon things
probably making her own granola and
whatever they do in
Oregon and you are just
suffering so I'm going tell you I would
recommend choosing grief choose
heartache be sad write a letter that you
will never
send just get out of out of your body
onto a page write a letter says I'm
sorry that this didn't work out I really
really loved you poured into you I miss
you and I had this picture of us going
side by side right or die you're you're
relationship you are a couple friends
and it's not going to happen you're
going to miss out and I wish you the
best and then you got to go do the hard
work of making new friends friends in
your local
area and you're worth every minute of it
we'll be right
back hey what's up delone here listen
you and me and everybody else on the
planet has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non-anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful nonanxious
life get your copy today at johal.com
all right as we wrap up today's show
we're going with another am I the
problem it's me go for it Kelly all
right so this lady asked not to be
identified so we won't let's call her
Jenna no okay oh no it's not one of
those all right cool it's not all right
all right all right my brother-in-law
grabbed my breast this summer while I
was getting my kids out of the car see
now you know why I didn't want to call
her Jenna while she was getting her kids
yeah later he claimed that he didn't
remember it because he had been drinking
his drinking has been an issue and made
us uncomfortable in the past but this is
a new level when I told my husband about
what happened he called him to discuss
it and he apologized to my husband and
said he felt terrible my husband told
him that he owes me an apology called
him to discuss
it my
husband all right yeah we wouldn't be
discussing much my husband told him he
owes me an apology and it's been 5
months and he still has not apologized
we are expected to spend the holidays
with the family along with our annual
Beach vacation next summer I don't want
to be around him am I the problem for
asking my husband and kids to skip out
this year if he is present if he
apologizes should we make a rule SL
bound
that he can't drink around us or we will
leave I love him and his family and my
husband has been very supportive and
understanding we don't want to hurt my
awesome in-laws either am I the
problem I can't
even oh my
gosh there's so many problems
here and I don't think she's any of them
no 99 problems and she ain't one she
ain't
one she who does not want to be
identified you are not the problem
problem number one your brother-in-law
blew up your family when he decided to
grab your boob while you were getting
your kids he
sucks I don't want to hurt my family you
didn't he went to grabin he ruined it
that's number one number two your
husband
sucks not just because he called to
discuss it God I hope you were
underselling that by A Thousand
Miles he sucks because he hasn't looked
at you and said we are never going out
with that dude again
period
period because if I'm in his presence
I'm go to
jail cuz he grabbed your goods while you
were trying to get the
kids it's not your Beach vacation to
cancel it's your husband coming to you
saying guess what honey and kids we're
doing different stuff cuz my brother
sucks and my family's too cowardly to
kick him
out
Tada I can't
believe
by the way I can't believe your husband
is
it I don't that that that apolog is
coming soon what what good is that
that's like used toilet paper I don't
want it I don't want it around me
ew plus a guy that sucks that bad
is of course he's not going to
apologize and by the way he
remembers he
remembers all of it all of it oh was
drinking can do he remembers I promise
you so
no absolutely
not ever be in that dude's presence
again the fact that you can say I love
him and his family e that's where you're
the problem a little bit
but rock on till the break of dawn
sister it is new family tradition time
for y'all because you got gropey McGee
as a
brother-in-law and you've got
a just like a bag of wet bread for a
husband and all of it makes me
go gross Kelly am I right yes except the
wet bread gross I know wet bread but him
gross yeah the whole thing hey husband
to she who does not want to be named
really
really grow up I don't say this very
often but a man plan your own vacation
you're done with
grer
ridiculous
[Music]
bye